ils ont fait le buzz avec ce clip tourné
à Paris une anecdote qui s'est
transformée en succès pour le groupe
électro Make The Girl Dance
à un groupe qui s'appelait
des tractions
très drôles et on avait demandé une
copine qui partage les bureaux qui est
auteur comique moi j'avais trouvé le
refrain baby baby et je lui ai dit écrit
des paroles sur une nana parisienne un
peu arrogante et tout et après moi
j'avais envie de faire un clip parce que
j'aime avec les frites j'aime la clé
crie et mais on avait pas d'argent donc
il fallait trouver une idée et venu ici
d'un genre de flash mob parce que
c'était ça l'idée c'était l'époque en
plein boom et d'une nana qui chantait
vraiment toute nue
au-delà de la musique la vidéo constitue
un élément fondamental pour le duo
aujourd'hui de tourner la musique elle
ne s'écoute plus et ce regarde certaines
quand tu écoutes la musique tu vas sur
Youtube et même dans les soirées les
gamins
donc du coup moi au début c'était un
truc déconsidéré toutes les études la
musique et tu fais de la vidéo mais en
fait un projet c'est tout si la vidéo
intéresse tant le groupe c'est peut-être
aussi parce que Pierre Mathieu a
longtemps sévi à la télévision notamment
comme animateur sur la chaîne M6 il y a
5 ans Pierre rencontre le musicien Greg
avec qui il se lit d'amitié s'en suivra
l'envie commune de créer il en découlera
un album électro sorti en 2011 quand on
a créé l'album on s'est dit on va pas
faire un genre puis si on fait un truc
ce qu'on joue nous en fait c'est un peu
dur si on se dit si on fait un album que
ça c'est une écoutable ça n'a aucun
intérêt donc du coup on s'est laissé
aussi écrire des trucs plus sobre plus
pop plus machin avec juste un fil
conducteur dans le sang il y a des
morceaux justement un comédie un peu
bourrin tu as des morceaux un peu
tristoun justement un peu pop comme on
est comme on écoute nous chez nous sans
oublier les titres baby Kill Me broken
Toy Boy ou encore Tchiki Tchiki le
groupe se produira dans les Yvelines le
16 février à Limay et le 23 février à la
clef Saint-Germain